[Music]
there's no place like home and for chef
nick fields that's phoenix arizona where
one of her passions is highlighting
local business ours is too nick and
watch this very special hometown tour
hi drew it's chef nick i'm here at
arizona's family studios in phoenix
arizona one of the things i love about
my hometown of phoenix is it has 365
days of sunshine come on let me show you
welcome to tempe beach park you have
people that are riding their bikes
people walking skateboarding paddle
boarding
at night time there's concerts it's a
really happening spot
we're here at the beautiful desert
botanical garden i love this place
because i used to take my daughter here
when she was little they have the most
beautiful butterflies and they have over
50 000 types of plants we are here with
dana the director of marketing dana can
you tell us a little bit about what
makes this place so special the garden
is just such an icon in the valley we're
filled with all these beautiful desert
plants from around the world plus we
have the most beautiful exhibitions and
events throughout the year it's just a
great place to immerse yourself in
nature and explore the desert
[Music]
i'm here at mary cole's ice cream shop
the oldest ice cream parlor in the state
but also home of my favorite dessert the
root beer float oh my god it's so yummy
howard what makes merry cold so special
why should people visit here well for
one thing we've been serving up smiles
one scoop at a time for 70 years
and now we're here at chic chef
marketplace i create every single
product that is on the shelf
not only is it created by me it's
created with love it's just a beautiful
snapshot of this beautiful town of
phoenix i can't wait for you to come and
visit yourself see you soon
wow nick i'm bursting with hometown
spirit and that's not even my hometown
although i do love phoenix arizona the
last time i was there i went to taliesin
west the frank lloyd wright house i
can't wait to come back thanks for
showing us around
[Music]
you